so for today's classic interview we're
gonna go back to November of 2015 I
interviewed Kurt Davies about how the
climate denial industry works and since
the interview we've actually learned
much more about how this is an industry
right this is not just individuals who
happen to disagree with the consensus on
climate change this is actually a funded
industry it's connected to fossil fuel
companies and other that benefit from
the use of fossil fuels and of having
huge carbon footprints and it is
particularly relevant right now as we
actually are closer at least
technologically and ideologically to
being able to get off of fossil fuels
all together but still lack the sort of
political will to do it so let's go back
to 2015 how the climate denial industry
works with Kurt Davies I'm joined today
by Kurt Davies who's director of the
climate investigation Center it's a
research group that works to expose the
anti environmental movement including
those that try to stall and block policy
solutions to climate change
Kurt you you were involved in this
extraordinary investigation into Willy
soon and the way in which climate denial
is funded before we talk specifically
about that investigation talk to us
generally about why in spite of the fact
that the overwhelming mountain of
scientific evidence points to humans
impacting the climate on earth we still
see so much of the so many of the same
view climate skeptics cited time after
time by the deniers why are we seeing
that well first of all thanks for having
me on the show and this is one of my
favorite subjects and I kind of obsess
about the answer to your question so I
could go on for hours but we don't have
that much time the the basic thing is
that they know these fossil fuel
corporations who don't want us to get
down and solve climate change to start
implementing you know real energy policy
that cuts out fossil fuels basically
they know that science is the engine
that drives policy along that you know
if we are not certain about whether the
Hudson River is polluted we won't do
anything about it if we're not certain
that
climate change is caused by fossil
fuel-burning we won't do anything about
it so they've funded their own echo
chamber they've sort of cultivated
people who will say things that the
companies themselves can't be caught
dead saying and Willie soon is a perfect
example of this
he and his his ally there at the
harvard-smithsonian Center for
Astrophysics Sally Bali Yunus who
retired suddenly in 2009 four years have
denied ozone the ozone hole they've
denied climate change they say it's
caused by sunspots or variations in the
Sun that the warming we're seeing today
is caused by something else and Exxon
funded them the Koch foundation funded
them American Petroleum Institute
Southern Company a huge utility based in
Georgia all funded Willy soon to put
this counter-narrative out that the
science is uncertain or that there are
other things to explain the warming that
we're experiencing talk to us a little
bit about let's stick with Willy soon
because it's just a good example a
microcosm of so much of what's going on
Willy soon a solar physicist as you
mentioned at the harvard-smithsonian
Center for Astrophysics he claims of all
of the different things you talked about
including changes in temperature dudu
merely due to sunspots the Sun just sort
of the the natural cyclical reality of
the Sun how is he funded specifically in
other words we might have this idea in
our heads that someone comes to him and
says listen Willy we need you to say
these things here's some money but
that's not really the way it actually
happened yeah no in fact it's more
complicated than that he actually
believes what he's saying it's not like
they are literally manufacturing doubt
or they are you know finding a scientist
and say go live for us they have found
scientists that think climate change
isn't real and then they have given them
a megaphone and they've given them
funding this if you go back to a
document that was leaked in 1998 there
now I'm getting some echo I'm sorry good
on your end yeah we're fine apologize so
in in 1998 there was a document that was
to the New York Times that showed a
multi-million dollar plan to funnel
money from industry trade associations
through front groups to basically media
trained scientists and give them venues
to talk to insert uncertainty into the
dialogue and they explicitly say victory
will be achieved when media legislators
even science teachers believe there is
uncertainty Willy soon was a direct
conduit where they sent money straight
to his institution to pay for his
research and the the payback was Willy
soon publishing peer-reviewed literature
in the in the scientific journals that
would you know generate some uncertainty
so it's a it's sort of a feeder system
that they developed a network of front
groups being libertarian anti and
anti-environmental anti regulatory
organizations and trade associations
like the American Petroleum Institute
they run money through those groups and
they prop up the scientists in the
public dialog so there it would be it
would be sort of too obvious if they
just say hey we want you to say these
things that you may not believe the the
the smarter way to go about it is fine
if only this tiny percentage share our
views let's exclusively fund those and
make them prominent and known that's
exactly right and what's fantastic about
this new exon investigation that's
rolled out over the past couple months
through a group called inside climate
news and online news source on climate
change and a group at Columbia School of
Journalism working with the LA Times
they both have revealed old exon
documents showing that Exxon knew much
more about climate science than we
previously knew they did and then they
went on to fund people like Willie soon
in one case there's a document from the
mid 90s where Mobil Oil scientists are
being are briefing the entire industrial
coalition the Global Climate Coalition
which was this front group set up to
block the Kyoto Protocol and block the
UN
process that's happening right now in
Paris they had a whole coalition to stop
that their own scientists said arguments
like Willy suman's sunspots arguments
that there's a divergence in the
temperature record they basically
knocked down each of those arguments and
say they really don't hold water to
explain the warming that we're seeing
and then they didn't include that in the
final draft that went public of that
document so this private conversation
inside the industrial block they knew
these arguments didn't hold water Exxon
goes on to promote those same arguments
in years subsequent let me ask you a
little bit Kurt and we're speaking with
Kurt Davies director of the climate
investigation Center increasingly we are
seeing from from the sort of the usual
suspects the talking point touted that
hey everything's fine as far as ice melt
that we now see more ice than ever in
the Arctic for example have you
investigated that what's what's going on
with that the resurgence of that talking
point that we're hearing lately well
first of all it's one of the biggest
calamities the meltdown of the Greenland
ice sheet and West Antarctic ice sheets
if they proceed as they are right now we
are in for a lot more sea level rise
it's where most of the ice that's above
sea level on earth is being stored right
now if they all if all that melts we get
like 30 feet of sea level rise it's a
big deal so cities like New York Miami
Philadelphia others are buried there so
that's the reason that they don't want
that to be true or don't want that the
uptake of that risk to be seen in the
public dialogue the the resurgence is
because it's getting worse and also
because there is increased press
attention to it and so the counter
narrative is rising up and talked a
little bit about where you know that
they claim to have science on their side
right they claim to say hey if we just
look at the volume of this ice we have
actually seen an increase and of course
what what they would like to see follow
from that
if there's more ice clearly things
aren't warming everything's fine look in
the other direction that's right and
there is no evidence that that is
occurring in the north in Antarctica
there was a study just a little while
ago that showed more snowfall than they
had previously measured in other parts
of Antarctica that we're adding ice
incrementally but the scientists
concluded it wouldn't it wouldn't
balance out the ice that's being lost
off of the West Antarctic Ice Sheet
which is really the biggest chunk that's
falling into the ocean on a regular
basis so ice is a big question it's you
could call it an uncertainty but all the
news is bad so it's not a you know the
best way to think about this is the the
deniers characterize it as a house of
cards argument that if one piece of the
scientific puzzle is missing everything
is everything falls away it's not true
the better way to look at it is like a
giant jigsaw puzzle and yes in all
science there is continuing exploration
and fine-point
certainty but the bigger the picture
gets you sort of know the picture before
you've done the puzzle it's the way to
look at it you know this is a picture of
a pretty grim scene adding the other
pieces are not going to make that scene
into some beautiful sunrise so the the
argument that we are missing information
and that's a reason not to act is
completely destructive right and not to
mention that even even if scientists are
wrong about 80 percent of their
predictions just if they're right on 20
percent we've still got a lot of stuff
to figure out and and you're absolutely
spot-on with that we've been speaking
with Kurt Davies director of the climate
investigation Center Kurt thanks so much
for talking to us and for your
investigations hey great at anytime
thank you